Speaker 1: Let's go next to is it
Nathan from Green Acres? Is that right?
Speaker 2: Yeah, that's right. I can't. I spoke
with you before. Couple of months ago. Okay.
Last time we spoke, I was running for office, but
I went to 41% of the first time. Candidate is all
right. All right. Four questions, just two. But
first, I just want to recommend, if you're going
to use protein powder, you probably want to
use it if you're lifting. Just like protein
powders, like you want to get big. But yeah.
Speaker 1: No, I was kidding when I asked. I'm
not really looking to use protein powder.
Speaker 2: Yeah, you look like a healthy
individual, so. You good? Thank you. But my first
question is, I feel like a lot of the momentum
is changing with the midterms. I think Florida is
an excellent example of this. I actually noticed
this and nobody's really talking about this.
But in the Democratic primary this time around,
there were more people that voted than people that
voted in 2018. And that surprised me because 2018
had more candidates. 2018 was supposed to be
a blue wave year, but we have more Democrats
voting now in Florida. We didn't really have
a real Republican primary. But I'm curious
if Democrats do well in the primary this
time around or excuse me, in the midterm,
Fetterman wins in Pennsylvania. The Democratic
Senate candidate in Wisconsin wins maybe even Val
Demings and Charlie Crist win. That'd be great.
That would be great. But where do Democrats go
from there? Because they have potentially expanded
the majority in the Senate. I don't know so much
about the House. I have some positive news
for the House. We have more progressives.
MAXWELL Well, Alejandro Frost from Florida as
well. But where do Democrats go for the rest
of the Biden administration from 2022 to 2024?
Speaker 1: I have no idea. And I actually spoke
about that with Congressman Ro Khanna earlier
in the week, because the way that Republicans
are going to function is as follows If Democrats
maintain the Senate but lose the House, which is
right now the most statistically likely outcome,
even though the momentum continues to shift,
Democrats will get obstructed by Republicans
on everything they do other than Supreme Court
picks. If Biden gets another Supreme Court pick,
they'll be able to get it through. But otherwise,
Republicans are going to stand in the way of
everything. And then when it comes to 2024,
they'll say Democrats did nothing for you for the
last two years, thanks to us. But they won't say
that you should vote for a Republican. And, you
know, even in my conversation with Ro Khanna,
he said, well, people won't fall for that.
People will know. I don't know. I don't know.
I'm not sure about that. So I think that's
a very difficult scenario and I don't really
have an answer, but I think it's a likely one.
Speaker 2: Yap, yap, yap, yap. That makes sense.
That makes sense. And I guess my second question
I'll try to be quick with this one is have you
ever considered speaking at college campuses?
Speaker 1: Because I've done
it before. I've done it before.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Well, would you want to
do it anytime soon? After you. Florida. Florida.
Speaker 1: So here's the deal. I'll be totally
honest and forthright with you, so I don't do
it for free, right? Because it's usually like
three total days of travel. It often takes me
away from the show, whereas which is how I make
money or I lose a weekend. And especially
now with a baby at home, it's really got to
be worth it for me to do that. And you know, most
colleges, they just don't really have the budget.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: For liberals,
for conservatives, they have great budget. For
conservatives. They'll bring in Ben SHAPIRO and
Michael Knowles and they'll pay out the wazoo. But
for liberals, they tend not to have the budget.
Speaker 2: Yeah. No, that's what it
was. That reasonable. I appreciate
the directness with that and I appreciate
your answer to my question and I appreciate
your content. All right. Thanks so much.
Speaker 1: All right, Nathan from Green Acres,
great to hear from you. We're going to take
the briefest of breaks. So if you're holding
on to talk to me, don't hang up because I'm
going right back to the phones in a moment